hello and welcome my name is Meredith
Melnick and I am the health director at
The Huffington Post in today's moderator
our hour-long program is a collaboration
between the forum at the Harvard th Chan
School of Public Health and the
Huffington Post the event also is part
of the dr. Lawrence H and Roberta Kohn
forum series welcome to dr. and mrs.
Cohen today's discussion will be an
exploration of the role and promise of
telehealth both in the United States and
internationally at the end of the
discussion we will take questions from
the online and studio audiences
questions for the panelists can be
emailed to the forum at HS pH
harvard.edu or they can be tweeted to at
forum HS pH using hashtag telehealth
forum you can also participate in a live
chat discussion that's happening on the
forum website right now now I'd like to
introduce today's panelists Ashish Shah
is a professor of international health
and director of the Harvard Global
Health Institute here at the Harvard th
Chan School of Public Health
Marc Mitchell is the founder and
president of D Tree International a
clinical decision support software
company and also a lecturer at the
Harvard th Chan School of Public Health
Randall Moore is the president of Mercy
Virtua which will open its first virtual
Care Center in Missouri next month
Steve Crossan who joins us remotely
leads public health initiatives at
Google and Loreen McCarthy who is also
joining us remotely is acting chief
consultant for telehealth services at
the US Department of Veterans Affairs
and to get started I'd like to start
with you as she SH let's start at the
top can you please define telehealth and
can you tell us how long this technology
has been around and how it has improved
and been implemented over the years
sure so remember to thank you for having
me here and I am gonna take about three
minutes to provide an overview on
telehealth sort of what it is how it
works what we know about the evidence
base and then I'm gonna turn it over to
mark and the rest of the panelists we'll
get into very specific uses and
instances of how telehealth is used so
if you look up the definition of Global
Health I mean Oklahoma telehealth
you will find lots and lots of
and conceptions of what it is but there
are a few concepts that are recurring
and I want to kind of identify those the
fundamental notion behind telehealth is
that it is about using electronic tools
to provide care remotely right it's a
tool usually uses some sort of
electronic technology and it's about
provisions of care remotely so that is
in some ways the fundamental idea of
behind telehealth it's used in lots of
different ways it's been around for a
long time
radiology is probably the place where
it's been used the most in healthcare
and certainly the longest the notion
that you take a film and then some
remote radiologist sitting in a dark
room hundreds of miles away might read
it and might give you their professional
reading but over the last 5-10 years
what we've seen is an explosion of
telehealth use in lots of other parts of
healthcare so in the management of
chronic disease in the management of
mental health really in lots of ways
we're seeing telehealth being used to
provide daily ongoing care to patients
telehealth comes in variety of different
forms the classic one is sort of we talk
about a synchronous technology kind of a
video you're sitting there in front of a
physician or a nurse and you're as a
patient describing your symptoms and the
person can make the diagnosis that's
kind of classically how we think about
it but there's a lot of asynchronous use
so asynchronous would be something like
a physician takes a photograph of a skin
lesion sense it off and a dermatologist
six eight hours later or even the next
day might review it and give his or her
assessment of what's going on and then a
major use of telehealth is around remote
monitoring and here the idea is an e I
see you by the way sort of probably the
most widely used and well-known of this
which is you have a physician sitting
somewhere far away monitoring ICU
patients in a hospital maybe hundreds or
thousands of miles away but there are
lots of ways in which you can use remote
monitoring the fundamental notion of
telehealth is that it is platform
agnostic and what I mean by that is you
can be doing this using a PC you can be
doing this on it on a tablet you can be
doing this on a mobile phone so how
widespread is the use of of telehealth
well I would argue that
we don't really have a great a great
precise number but share a few data
points with you guys so form a survey
about two years ago of American
hospitals about half of all American
hospitals said they were using
telehealth on a regular basis that
number in the last couple years has
probably grown and I would say that that
probably was an underestimate and so if
you just look at the US you would assume
that a vast majority of hospitals now
are using telehealth in one form or
another and obviously this is not just
about hospitals provide organizations of
all kinds are using it internationally
we don't have comparable data so I can't
tell you what that number looks like in
England or Denmark or Germany but if you
look across high and now low and middle
income countries you see massive
investments happening and telehealth
countries around the world are using
this a lot more whether it's for mental
health care in Canada or for focusing on
an older population in Australia there's
an incredible program that's trying to
figure out how to keep rural older
people in Australia at home for longer
than they would have otherwise using
telehealth so a lot of creative uses
across the globe and you'll hear about a
bunch more of those so the big question
of course is does it work
and what do we mean by does it work well
does it improve access does it improve
quality does it lower cost I would argue
that the evidence here is still pretty
early it's not very strong but it is
growing rapidly
where the evidence is best as it
improves access especially for people
who don't have access to physicians and
nurses there is some evidence that it
leads to better care where the evidence
is the weakest is around cost savings
it's been chattered catted about a lot
that somehow this is a technology that's
going to save us a lot of money
I am deeply skeptical I have not seen
the evidence that it is a big cost
saving my take is it is worth doing for
the quality and access alone if there
are cost savings to be had we have not
yet seen them blast point we know
telehealth is important because we're
starting to see pushback I don't know if
you many of you saw in a couple of weeks
ago in the New York Times there was a
piece about that how the Texas Medical
Association is basically trying to block
the growth of telehealth across Texas
their argument
is that patients should have established
relationships with physicians before
they use technologies like this it's
based on a sort of a patient safety
argument they're trying to protect
patients from telehealth my take is that
they're trying to protect their
pocketbooks and not as focus on actual
outcomes for patients so here we are
I think the dawn of a new technology
revolution in healthcare telehealth is
going to be one of the critical elements
that's going to be very important in
changing the way we deliver care to our
patients it is not like most
technology's not a silver bullet but if
we can figure out how to use it
effectively and efficiently I think you
can have very substantial effects on the
health of populations thank you so much
for that and just to tease out when one
point you mentioned had the effect on
access for rural communities and so you
know I think that's something
interesting about telehealth that it
actually is most sophisticated in places
with the fewest resources and to help
illustrate that further I'd like to turn
things over to Marc who's going to
introduce us to a brief video clip that
demonstrates how telemedicine is being
used in a rural clinic in Malawi thank
you in much of the world people never in
their lifetime will see a doctor the
only health worker they'll see lives in
the community and has perhaps six weeks
of training following primary school so
let me introduce you to say team akela
who's a community health worker in rural
Malawi a poor country in East Africa I
never stayed in Massena
welcome my data Iowa but 2000 2015
people in joining the situation yeah I
don't read this and the five children
when they're good maybe my fever
diarrhea and first bleeding sometimes
delight that's what I do
this was just we register the names of
date
Chelsea child and their phone negative
keeps that data in Haiti July student
off and that's what gives us because
that's how we can treat the child maybe
he doesn't the amount of medication up
to give the church and also maybe
somebody vices within the phone I think
it's a very cool thing people keep using
the greater good
the cell phone that society uses runs an
app that was created by a d3
international and it takes him step by
step through an assessment of the sick
child it identifies a correct diagnosis
correct treatment including dose how
often cetera it also stores the record
for use by Sayyidi when he sees that
person again and by his supervisor today
this app and others like it are being
used by thousands of health workers in
Africa to improve child health
facilitates safer deliveries for mothers
and newborns provide family planning and
other health services we believe that
everyone no matter who they are or where
they live has a right to high quality
health care and that technology is a
central part of bringing that care to
people in rural Malawi and other parts
of the world where otherwise they would
not have access to this level of health
care telehealth obviously has a role to
play in in the clinic visits but it also
has a role in crises and pandemics last
year as Ebola was moving swiftly across
several West African countries Google
created an app that helped aid workers
access medical records so I'd like to
actually go to the monitor and talk to
Steve can you tell us more about project
when dia and some of the other Google
initiatives in the space you guys give
me okay great so I'll talk about project
windier in just a moment
strictly speaking that's not a location
although there's an application that
applies technology to a medical
situation but of what I would say is
that Google by default ends up being one
of the most consulted telehealth
services in the world and because when
people are unwell what do they do and
they don't go to Google and they make us
for symptoms and this has been something
that has long troubled us Google because
as medical professionals we'll know the
quality of answers that you get from the
Internet
when you have a question about your
health is not always terrific and as a
result of that just recently we launched
in the u.s. a set of much more curated
experiences which had been vetted by a
panel of the bots for the top end
conditions and symptoms and treatments
that people searched for and which also
then fall through to no rated further
places that you could go you know
clinics that you can call help lines
that you can call but further and more
detailed information in passing your
article physician when appropriate so I
think that that the fact that you know
users right across the world that are
coming to Google and other services for
health information is evidence of the
demand for these sorts of services we're
still frankly as in the early stage in
their development but we hope that this
is really a first step towards making
that particular experience much better
we also in the public health group that
we will see a strong role for technology
conditions you know way across the world
including the Ebola project that you
mentioned at the outbreak of Ebola in
West Africa we were contacted by a
variety of organizations one of which
was medicine Frontier Doctors Without
Borders who really wanted to see whether
they could use technology to solve a
problem that they were facing in their
clinics in the field which was that
doctors in the field wearing personal
protective equipment were in a very high
risk high infection environment I think
it difficult to get round
get through ward rounds with perhaps 200
patients one award they had a limited
amount of time to get around any
equipment that was taken into the room
could not be taken out again so the
state of the art for patient notes was
really writing down notes on pieces of
paper and then chatting them across the
fence do a copic he would write them
down and then a third party would enter
them into an Excel spreadsheet restore a
database on top this was an environment
with without power or at least without
regular and reliable power without
internet connection and so we worked
with them when it was very much doctors
without borders who did a lot of design
to try to solve to see what how
technology could help solve that
particular problem which is really the
problem of use of technology in a
high-risk and very remote environment
the result of that was a project called
project by BIA which you can see at the
project when the org and which is now
deployed in the field and it's an
open-source project we're now building a
consortium of health partners in the NGO
world to take that project forward and
hopefully get it to have value in in our
Wiccans and in other situations beyond
the bola as well wonderful thank you
Steve I want to bring things back to a
national setting and turn to Randall we
have a video clip of some of the work
that Mercy virtual has been doing to
bring telemedicine to the hospital
setting so let's run that and then we
can we can go to you
morning miss Brooke's this is Susie from
safe watch we're just another pair of
ice for the nurses and the doctors down
there you glad to be out of that bed
from this floor at Mercy Hospital in
creve coeur missouri physicians and
nurses monitor intensive care patients
from all across the Midwest this
telemedicine program is called safe ones
and it's part of mercies I see you using
today's technology these caregivers are
a second line of defense we're saving
lives in a few ways obviously the big
AHA and the great catches are great so
it's great when we see something going
on and we can intervene before things
trend and get really bad we also do a
lot of quality things so we do
day-to-day quality checks quality
rounding sorts of things in real time
and we're able to to make changes in
real time that affect the long term
foundation it really is remarkable what
what one can do with the the technology
when it is put in place when the
infrastructure is put in place as an
example in the ICU which is probably the
highest intensity of monitoring that one
normally sees if a nurse walks out of
the room it is possible for the
respirator to fall off it is possible
for the IVs to stop and that certain
warnings don't trigger for seconds to
minutes whereas on the other hand if
you're being monitored through the EIC
you it is almost instantaneous when that
a safety measure is noted and corrected
the technology if you is is so
remarkable that you can take the the
camera and focus down to the the pupils
of the patient that down to there people
are dilatation as to whether or not
there's any changes in the patient's
condition mercy safe watch started in
2006 its success has led to a
proliferation of telemedicine programs
today more than 70 are in motion I want
to go over the results for your last
ultrasound and talk about here maternal
fetal medicine specialist dr. Jim
borrows mine
connects with the pregnant patient
worried about a recent decrease in fetal
movement the last option you had and
everything looking great the baby is
growing normally if you have a nurse on
the other end you can do she can do part
of the physical exam if need be
obviously stenographers is doing the
ultrasound nurses may also be doing
other fetal monitoring and so we're able
to pretty much provide every degree of
care that I would have been doing a
consult here in the office if the
patient we're sitting next to me these
patients are communities where there's
not subspecialty care available such as
us so they would have to travel and take
off work for a full day plus a lot of
times they have to do follow-up testing
fetal testing on once or twice a week so
it's a great convenience to them plus
they have readily ready access to us
great so Rhonda can you walk us through
some of the applications in the hospital
setting and then also what this means
for the the virtual Center that you're
that you're creating sure thing mercy is
a relatively good size organization
situated through the Midwest we have 35
hospitals a couple of thousand fully
integrated physicians seven hundred
vance providers 300 plus clinic sites
and we've been on a ten year roughly
intentional transformation to as we say
get healthcare right to build to build a
new model and it's not hard to
understand if you think I want to have
people think about incrementally as well
as disruptive on the incremental side a
safe watch which is our II ICU program
or any number of continuous 24-hour day
monitoring programs we can fill gaps we
can be at the bedside when somebody else
is not and the interesting of what you
finally even when it had 24-hour
intensive us putting the ESU in place
the safe watch program what we saw is a
consistent trend that keeps improving to
where our apache adjusts our risk
adjusted mortality is 30 plus percent
less than predicted or like the stays
are much less than predicted in that
environment by filling in gaps right
thing faster we can give better outcomes
to people and we've taken the same
consistency and done that across no of
areas we've done it in sepsis and we've
moved from monitoring the first sepsis
beds to we're just approaching 3,000
beds across our system that are
monitored real-time 24 hours a day now
it's just not about telemedicine it's
about what goes with it if you just look
at monitor somebody nothing changes
monitor with a complete rework of the
workflow makes a huge difference so part
of our intentional journey is how can we
complete the care continuum Xin side of
a hospital making work 24/7 how can we
extend what our doctors what our
clinical teams do and bring it to people
where they are can we have patients who
live in rural Arkansas get the same
level access to care as people who live
in Springfield or st. Louis in the
answers in the journey yes we can get
there we can bring care to people when
and where they need it so if you think
about the transformation that technology
can enable I have a tendency to think of
a hospital as it as a place to bring
providers and patients together with all
the technology and resources so that we
can build a care plan and with that care
plan we can put an expert in their inner
district team around that care plan and
with that we can take a patient for
instance with heart failure number one
cause of hospitalization who's coming in
on the Brinks of death perhaps and four
or five days later we're sent them out
relatively in good shape compared where
they started we do that through pretty
simple things a team a plan monitoring
against it and making sure the right
person is getting that person at the
right time I think of five to ten years
we're going to look back we're going to
realize what some people have thought
which is that a lot of chronic disease
which is increasingly taking a majority
of our hospital beds that those should
become ambulatory conditions because
what do we do in the hospital we put a
plan together we hook up to the patient
we monitor against that plan when
something triggers the right person
comes the patient I used to oversee an
emergency room in a university setting
and we developed a neat program where we
integrated our emergency room
with our clinic trying to create a
continuum and we did some pretty cool
stuff but what I realized can after the
fact is a lot of times the person
showing up in the emergency room who was
going to get admitted for heart failure
is somebody I should have seen two days
ago but I had no clue that I needed to
see him I didn't have the technology to
do it but with telemedicine that
technology exists and so it's going to
get better it's gonna get cheaper it's
going to get easier to use but
progressively it's a journey to move
from a bimodal health system and when I
say bimodal health system most of us are
trained inside of a hospital and it's
incredible to care to get inside of a
hospital but when you leave that
hospital you go from integrated complete
care to kind of reacted fragmented care
so if you think about telemedicine a
little different about virtual care it's
the ability for us to extend our care
teams from the institution to the
patient to take our patient centric
approach that we've learned how to do
and get the highest value inside of a
hospital and why can't we make that
patient centricity work 24/7 365 with us
proactively bringing care to a patient
instead of waiting for the patient to
come to us it's not easy it's a it's a
challenging solution to put it all
together and I'll I'll stop here and say
four questions the other side is if we
could for instance make heart failure an
ambulatory condition today
why isn't it being done I hope you think
about that we'll come back to it yes I'm
very interested to come back to that but
first I want to turn to Maureen the VA
is the country's largest integrated
health care system and so you know the
way that they use telehealth has
implications across the country can you
talk a little bit about the presence of
telehealth at the VA sure thank you
thanks for inviting us to present it I
just wanted to give first of all a
little probably a false separation but a
description of the three kinds of pala
health services that that VA provides
the first one has been spoken about the
clinical video telehealth which is a lot
like FaceTime or Skype in some ways but
may also
have monitoring components to it it that
in VA typically occurs real-time and it
started in VA in 2002 we've had over two
hundred and forty eight thousand vets in
the last fiscal year engaged in clinical
video visits we have over forty five
specialties represented so there is a
lot of buy-in or using this as a
particular technology that can be very
patient-centered we wouldn't want to
force anyone to do clinical video
telehealth if they're not interested but
certainly there are very many people
interested it cuts down very
significantly on travel time and
improves convenience for our veterans
the second one I wanted to talk about is
the home telehealth program and that's
what some of you have spoken up before
typically this involves the care and
case management with the monitoring for
some chronic conditions and it provides
that non institutional care support to
patients using in-home mobile devices to
manage diabetes or chronic diseases and
in particular as as was just mentioned
by Randall congestive heart failure very
sensitive conditions to the kind of
monitoring that needs to happen but this
is another example of care that doesn't
happen in a vacuum and it's not only
about the technology because we have the
care coordinators who interact with our
patients that are in the home we have
about a 1 to 100 ratio so each care
coordinator oversees 100 patients and
and the interventions can happen
relatively quickly something like CHF is
very sensitive to the weight of the
patient slight increases in weight make
you very concerned about fluid increases
and a retention and so the interaction
can happen without a visit to the to the
physician's office or anything and
real-time changes can be made to manage
that condition for last year we treated
over a hundred and fifty six thousand
veterans with home telehealth monitoring
this is something I think I mentioned
that began in 2003 over 40,000 of them
were veterans that we helped to live in
to
and I'm really happy to say that for
those veterans that received home
telehealth services and this is getting
an Ashes question about cost that the
average cost per patient saved per year
is $2,000 so that translates into for us
at fifty four percent decrease in bed
days of care and a thirty two percent
decrease in hospital admissions though
it really is a game changer and it
really is an investment that we feel is
worth making not only do we feel it but
the veterans who are able to stay in
their homes and the caregivers that get
that support feel that way as well the
last kind we generally conceptualizes
store and forward telehealth where it's
it's asynchronous as you men mentioned
for us the classic example is tell a
retinal imaging with telemental imaging
a veteran might need to have them back
their eyes imaged regularly because of
their diabetes this kind of screening
should happen on an ongoing basis but
imagine a veteran that comes to a
community-based outpatient clinic which
might be miles from the optometrist or
ophthalmologist we have telehealth
technology and that image is stored and
forward into an optometrist who or an
ophthalmologist who can read that and
make evaluations and judgments about who
should then be seen in the clinic that
is a real satisfier for our patients
because it cuts down on extra visits and
so forth fell asleep tells spirometry
telehomecare and all are part of this
and we had over three hundred and
seventy nine thousand episodes of care
like that last year I mean 379 thousand
unique veterans enrolled in that kind of
telehealth last year though I mentioned
a lot of numbers we've had last year 2.1
million
episodes of care with telehealth and 45
percent of the patients that we treat
live in rural areas which for VA is
really important because we have
distinct medical centers but we don't
want to feel like we're limited
providing care there
we have community-based outpatient
clinics and that's great but there are
people that live significant distances
from our community-based outpatient
clinics that we certainly want to be
able to be responsive to them and focus
on convenience as well though the other
statistic I want to share is the home
monitoring we use for mental health
conditions as well and that reduced so
when I give these statistics about
patient and bed days of care and so
forth
each patient is serving as his or her
own control in the year before we
started the home telehealth monitoring
to the year after that when I mentioned
reduced phase of days oops
reduced bed days of care that was a 54%
decrease for each patient and when I
mentioned hospital admissions that would
be a 32% decrease for that patient and
for telemental health conditions acute
psychiatric bed days of care there's a
35% decrease you may know that VA also
pays travel costs for veterans who have
service-connected conditions though we
also do have some savings and not
requiring veterans to travel we've
learned a lot we want to share a lot but
you know there is still plenty of
lessons to learn we have our large
system I sometimes have an I have a
dream speech like my dream is that we
will truly function as a system and that
when we have a need one place or a surge
in returning veterans in another place
that our system can rise up and usable
medicine to help our other kind of
facilities and partners so that we don't
have to worry about the boundaries of
where people are actually placed I that
we have barriers and I'm happy to talk
about the barriers I feel like I spend
the greater part of my time working down
the barriers but I just wanted to share
with you that as someone who practices
telemedicine from my desk right here
like this with this device I'm a
psychiatrist by training I I'm very
pleased to share with you my excitement
and VA is excitement about telehealth
wonderful thank you so to take the pin
back out and talk a little bit about
let's go let's go back and then let's go
forward so I'm
you know not a very new technology but
it seems to be having a greater pace of
applications now why do you think now
and and what has been the holdup and
then let's address maybe you know what
the pace is going to be going forward in
the next five to ten years so whoever
wants to wants to jump in just please do
maybe I can just start by saying I think
there's been some changes in technology
right so broadband has become more
ubiquitous video technology has gotten
better so there's a bunch of
technological changes that have been
very important I also think that we're
changing the way we're thinking about
care we're thinking more around
population health we're thinking a lot
more about cost we're thinking a lot
more about quality and you put all of
that together with a new set of
technologies and you get a renewed
attention and interest in something
that's been around for a long time but
now with a lot of new applications ona
had one new one other technology that's
changed and that's mobile technology you
know now each of us has a supercomputer
in our pocket and not only us but
everyone in the world does for the most
part this year 2015 is the year that
there will be more mobile phones in use
than there are people on the planet what
that means is that we can bring the
technology to individuals we can use it
in a wide variety of ways in the
processing power that's available to us
allows us to do all these magical things
that we couldn't do before
the other piece is healthcare isn't we
all know is facing significant headwinds
reimbursements coming down we can't
sustain the rate of increases of the
cost of care and it's challenging the
current model of care so as you talked
about before it's I think we're after a
2030 year journey a lot of a lot of
forces are aligning with one of the big
ones being as a society we need to make
differences and then as we've learned
over the years of what works and doesn't
work one of the big lessons and one
reasons we have a large dedicated Center
going up is to build a critical mass of
teams that can make this work and show
what it can do but over time
we're already actively in the effort is
how do we integrate this in the
day-to-day care of what clinicians do
throughout their day to where it's going
to be more and more I see a patient and
clinic I see a patient a hospital I go
on my clinic and I see two patients in a
room and I go and see two patient's
virtually and the people I'm seeing I'm
seeing kind of just in time it's a whole
lot of pieces to be put together
technology people are focused on and
it's a mistake made in business a lot of
times technology is only an enabler and
for you know every dollar you spend on
technology you'll spend another five or
six dollars and putting the team and
processors together behind it but the
lack of recognition of what is required
for a whole solution has really held us
up we put technology in place and it
goes into a system that works the way
it's always been and sunrise to work so
we need that the bright thinking of
people who are dedicated focused to this
who can show the power of what can be
done Maureen did you want to add to that
this morning sure I couldn't agree with
that statement more we talked a lot
about the concept of a digital dial tone
so that a provider could go from seeing
a patient in person to seeing a patient
by video to phone calls to you know e
consults or whatever it is that we're
doing but to make it not clunky excuse
the expression for the providers so that
they don't have to spend a lot of time
going through this system or that system
but just to have ease because I think
that's an important part of improving
access to care making sure we maximize
the providers time I mean yet also
having the flexibility for that provider
to move from person to person
I did mention our people and I couldn't
agree with you more
that we do need to have provider buy-in
but we also don't need to have support
like people handy if something goes
wrong with the technology or people
handy if we you know if we need to kind
of go the extra mile to engage a
particular veteran for us or something
like that but I would wholeheartedly
agree with what you're saying and this
kind of Dells back into what you'd said
initially Ashish about cost and and some
so I'm wondering if we can go back to
that and talk about what some of the
cost-saving measures there are and some
of the ones that are that are not yet in
place and maybe also lessons from
low-income countries that are informing
our care
here so if somebody else wants to lead
off I mean my overall sense is that the
opportunity for saving money here is
quite substantial this is a technology
that should replace a lot of the things
that we do now much of the data suggests
that it's been an additive not
necessarily a replacement that is not to
say therefore it'll never save money to
me it just means that not that the
technology has to get better than maybe
the technology also has to get better
but we have to figure out those
processes that you keep talking about
randall which i could not agree with
more to to really identify what
processes let you use the technology in
ways that you can save money and I would
say we're still early in the journey of
figuring that out to that point I think
the you know historically even within
institutions we've operated in silos
certainly across institutions we're in
silos and it creates a lot of
duplication replication and inefficiency
that in many ways financially we've all
been rewarded for we're all paid for
what we do but as as reimbursement
shifts to outcome for the individual for
subpopulations for populations the rules
change so we feel for instance we
shouldn't all be duplicating this we
should be working together across the
country as providers and bringing all
the stakeholders and to figure out how
to do this but we also have to deal with
the reality of I have been involved many
programs over the years that have showed
tremendous improvements and outcomes and
most of those became pilot projects that
never went anywhere and the reason is
that the elephant the room is the value
is being created but where's the value
going in whose pocket and for a hospital
let's let's use the heart failure again
if we eliminated say 2,000
hospitalizations for heart failure for a
system moderately-sized system and
they're getting $10,000 for each one of
those hospitalizations today on paper
most people say we're losing money on
those people because our fully loaded
cost raha spittle ization is $11,000 so
why not just stop it because when you
look at the real contribution to keeping
that system running there maybe five six
or seven thousand dollars of cash from
that hospitalization
that pays the for the people the care
teams not to be there so if you go back
to the ACO is that the answer I don't
think so because that think about the
ACL if you do a good job you're gonna
split up all a small piece of money 5050
but if you were the hospital from which
you put the effort in to build a virtual
care center and put teams a place all
knew we had a cost that by the way are
not reimbursed or are lightly reimbursed
and you took the hospitalization away
you may have increased your costs 25%
and you're getting to save part of the
hospitalization so when it comes to
splitting the benefit the payers gonna
keep 125 percent you're gonna be minus
25% from where you started and that
doesn't mean the ACL concept is wrong
but we've got to think about is how much
net value is created and we've got to
create glide paths to say if you've got
these expenses until you can take these
expenses out we've got to give you a
pathway to do it to actually split the
Bennett the net and benefit and reinvest
that so that we can improve the care
improve the models and shift to this
patient-centered care I think one of the
problems is that we're trying to do many
things because in fact creating new ways
of delivering care using technology
improves access improves quality I think
there is as she's mentioned evidence for
that the problem is that when you
measure the cost of those things you
measure in costs of more people being
involved in the system and who are
getting better care and so it may be
that the cost is going up or it may be
going up for one piece and coming down
as you mentioned for another piece but
few people are looking at the whole
system and saying what is the net change
in total costs to the system because
certainly in this country there is no
system and in most other places there
are just a multitude of players each of
whom only has a particular lens on the
problem so I think that kind of
system-wide looking at what's changing
and how are we going to measure costs in
a more rigorous way is really need
Maryna Steve this morning I'd like also
to add that you know our system has
built up as a kind of bricks and mortar
system and that's not my original term
certainly well smarter than me talk
about this all the time but you know
when you think about a system that it's
built up on a basis of a hospital based
care kind of like was mentioned before
this is a technology that crosses all of
that that we're talking about and so we
are all caught in some real
administrative barriers as a result our
system as a whole doesn't want to adapt
sometimes because of those those
barriers what how we measure our reuse
or how we capture workload or how we
determine a standard visit of giving
example teledermatology when people
forward a photo of a lesion well the
standard of care in dermatology is to do
a whole body scan but when people are
doing - hello darling that whole body
scan they're doing the photo that was
sent to them so how do we restructure
our concept of quality if what if what
we're doing with one exam might not be
the full criteria for another or but but
yet how do we ensure that patients
meanwhile are getting the care they need
I think the the connections the
information security and all of that
that are that we're used to in our kind
of bricks and mortar world are also
challenges but but the administrative
challenges I think are bigger than just
about any others that we've faced yes
one more thing and then let's go to the
question another pushback that commonly
comes is is isn't this can't be as good
as me saying the patient in the clinic
and the answer is absolutely it can't be
but I also push back right away and say
99% of the time we can't be where the
patient needs us when they need us so
it's not that clinic and live care ever
goes away it's that Ken again can we see
the heart failure patient two days
earlier via video and give a little
extra diuretic and tell them that user
option and
and check him back and avoid the ICU
intubation two days later
that little it wasn't as good as being
there in the clinic or a hospital no did
what was this effect potentially huge
we've got to recognize both though know
what people do today and give them new
tools then also give them the support to
do that absolutely so let's let's go to
the audience please
I'm dr. Cohen from the nearby Community
Hospital called the Brigham and Women's
Hospital it's around the corner many of
my colleagues primary care physicians
get four or five hundred emails a day
from their patients and it's very
helpful they save a lot of visits and
they save a lot of money by answering
these things but I'm gonna raise a very
provocative question to this panel
should these people these primary care
doctors that do all this telemedicine
should they be compensated for this in
some modest way I think they should
because I think that not only are they
having time their time utilization but
there's also medical malpractice
implication here as well and I just
wanted if the panel could adjust that I
think they should be compensated in a
new regulatory way which I think would
decrease hundreds of thousands of
unnecessary clinic visits
and they would still get some as you
said 99% good medicine but I think this
should be compensated and so I could I
have the panel answer that question so I
I would so dr. Donna I would agree with
that
wholly and and the way I would describe
it as I think we have to reconsider
their care physician and it is not just
about seeing people in clinic it's also
about answering emails it's also about
doing phone visits and if we think of
all of that as part of his or her job
then they should be getting paid for the
entire set of activities now whether you
do it as a salary or you do it as a fee
for each of the different elements I'm
more agnostic that people who feel like
everybody should be salaried that that's
fine but the bottom line is that what
has happened is we
still conceptualize the job as the
doctor visit in the clinic and then all
the stuff is add-on it can't be that way
it's not add-on it's actually core to
the functioning of a good primary care
physician looking at another way and as
a primary care physician at one point it
was I think my job should be to try to
optimize the health of the people I
serve how I was paid was for my
individual units of intervention I would
rather not see telemedicine virtual care
be yet another fee-for-service item
because then we're focused on the item
instead of the outcome so you know ways
to do that from the health plan side
would be take the primary care
physicians and they get $40 per person
per month in their panel for an average
person that can be a risk adjusted I get
a really sick patient that person might
be a thousand dollars a month because
I've got to spend a lot more time with
them then figuring out how to get them
what they need just in time the other
piece you mentioned we have to be very
very careful about virtual care and it
can be just slammed quickly great
studies showing the more you're
disrupted in your daily workflow the
less you didn't concentrate the more
mistakes are going to be made right
chuckles going on right away everybody's
been there that's actually part of the
reason we built a virtual care center
until we can work out the workflows we
want to put filters in place like
through our monitoring of all of our
beds we've reduced our alerts into our
nurses by 93 percent and the ones that
are going now they know they need to act
on as opposed to being bombarded with
thousands of interruptions a day so I'd
like to think more holistically and back
to the if our responsibilities and
keeping people in optimal health for
where they are may be again that's what
we pay for they do you want to take some
questions from my mind
yes thanks we do have a lot of questions
online so I'm going to offer a few of
them and unfortunately Steve cross and
did have to get off and I wanted to
include one of these questions before he
did but perhaps you can help us with
this mark in the era in the era of rapid
telehealth market growth the monitoring
regulation of health information on the
web is becoming complex especially in
developing countries where patients are
dependent on the web information rather
than upon physicians how can developing
countries best benefit from tell
when there is a big emerging market of
telehealth in these countries I think
the first real challenge is that most of
most emerging countries in fact most
countries really don't understand
telehealth they are way behind and don't
appreciate that it's something other
than sending a text message to remind a
patient to come to an appointment for
example maybe that's telemedicine but
it's pretty low lying fruit so I think
that the first real thing is that
countries rethink what they mean by a
health system delivering care and how
can they use technology to support that
do we want to filter how individuals
access information on the web I don't
know the answer to that but it's not my
area of expertise I don't think we're
likely to be able to do that in any case
but I do think that there's a need to
accept that people have access to all
kinds of information that that
technology is going to change the way
both information and care is being
delivered and how can we use that
effectively begins by recognizing that
it's not something to be avoided but to
be embraced thank you we are getting a
lot of questions about privacy issues
related to this so I did just want to
ask one of those does the use of
telehealth technology raise new privacy
and security questions could someone
electronically eavesdrop on
doctor-patient communication or
intercept or even tamper with the
results of tests that are delivered
online
what are telehealth telehealth experts
doing to protect patient privacy and
security the technologies exist today so
for instance you know FaceTime Skype the
original stuff out there was not made to
be medically secure yet it wasn't HIPPA
ready compliant but there are
ways to make the technology work so for
instance if somebody penetrates the
video stream it just disconnects so
security kimball but can be put in place
and I think the VA has been on the
cutting edge with its different layers
of security so I'll turn to Maureen like
we have the best answer yet but I do
feel like we have the security let me
just say that when in the mid 2000
decade is when we started with the
clinical video telehealth and in that
era the securest platform was this you
know he's aware clunky again rather
clunky platform of using multiple
sign-in similar to what we use for our
own clinical video and for a non
clinical video conferences and and
that's cumbersome but it met the need at
that point but that was 10 years ago and
we really really want to move toward a
system where we can use the smart phones
or other devices the patients have but I
have to tell you that we are very very
cautious because we want to ensure that
the care that the veterans that entrust
their care to us have their privacy
protected the last thing we would want
is anything to be broadcast over the
internet or anything like that
we have veterans who have a you know
served our nation and done amazing
things but also you know with terrible
struggles particularly related to PTSD
and some of them are reluctant to even
participate in clinical video telehealth
so we want to make sure we honor that so
we probably go very very far into the
security in an effort to prevent the
release of any kind of information but
we are looking at new ways and certainly
the new technology that's available the
clouds whether it can be within our
firewall and so forth
in order to allow for security and
decrease the clunkiness I can tell you
our home our home telehealth for
instance if there the input data for
instance when the page might put their
weight or vital signs or how their mood
is that particular day into the home
telehealth system it doesn't even go
directly to our patient medical record
it goes
site that the the care coordinators I
mentioned are able to access download
and enter into the record obviously we
want patient generated data to
communicate directly with our medical
record but you know we also want to have
the record have meaningful data so
that's that's a tightrope we're walking
right now in terms of understanding the
best way to get patient generated data
into our permanent records I think it's
an excellent question
I throw a tune to ask the audience and
to be thinking about also the practical
side security if anything is swung
fairly conservatively and trying to
protect everything for for laws lawsuits
and disrespecting individual but I can
also tell you and I've talked to many
many providers whether it's in the VA or
across other systems we have a lot of
people today who can't access care and
are literally dying oh and having
significant exacerbations that are
disease for the sake of privacy so as a
society I mean we have to take a step
backwards at times and ask the question
of what should be the balance
thank you I'll just do one more but we
have a really active chat so I encourage
everyone to go on we have had a number
of questions about billing Medicaid
Medicare so I'll just take this one how
should the American healthcare system
deal with billing and coding of
telehealth and telemedicine procedures
especially in the emergency department
and in rural settings where people
receiving the procedures may not be able
to afford them and some questions about
you know does Medicaid cover this
Medicare be great if someone could
address that I believe from a billing
perspective first of all my bias again
would be to be paying on the basis of
population and outcomes and forms of
capitation sub capitation tied outcomes
but until we do that until we align the
incentives also there are many states
Medicaid that are currently paying for
telehealth somewhere on par with ly
visits some are not a whole variety of
ways to do it we're always afraid as a
society if we put a code out there it's
going to be misused and maybe we just
start giving too much care again but
kept paying for appropriate care when we
can keep
people from needing to take the time to
schedule an appointment to further
deteriorate to come in later to drive
200 miles it does make so much more
sense for us to pay for a visit so long
as that visits delivering what needs to
be done and it can be another pathway
for us to get to population health and
the only thing a lot is I think you are
seeing increasingly both public and
private payers recognizing the value of
this kind of technology everybody's
doing it a little differently actually
think that's fine it's we're
experimenting that's kind of what the
right payment model is what the right
amount of payment ought to be and we
need to carefully study this stuff and
understand what's the optimal way to pay
for these services so we use just the
right amount to get the right care thank
you great so we like to end these
sessions by each contributing not not me
but you each contributing a policy take
away what is one thing that you can
think of what one impediment that could
be removed through a policy change that
would that would help to improve access
to telemedicine so mine would be to kind
of go back to the concern that I raised
initially where we are starting to see
some amount of pushback we have states
that are worried about this technology
look this is still in the early days I
think the potential benefit of this
technology is massive in terms of both
improving access quality and ultimately
lowering costs we have to give it some
Running Room we have to look try out
different models and not all of it will
work but and particularly for states
we've seen states that are very
restrictive have much lower levels of
adoption of these technologies the
people who lose in that context are the
patients who can't access high-quality
care and so my general takeaway is we've
got to give this technology a chance
mine would be similar that the changes
that are underway based on technology
are not going away
you know everybody will have mobile
phones and we'll use them
maybe we'll lose landlines and
healthcare will be delivered in
different ways in different places in
very poor countries it will use mobiles
that will do
use more non-physician providers in this
country will still have probably many
doctors but maybe other kinds of
providers and certainly telemedicine and
home monitoring I think the trick is to
as I said earlier to embrace the
technology and the changes rather than
to try to avoid it we'll come back to
our need to align incentives and to
understand that we're not talking about
technology we're talking about whole new
solutions and to create a glide path for
organizations that are primarily
Hospital based organizations large
clinics and find a way to open up those
walls maintain the current reimbursement
while you shift to bringing care to
patients and again that means don't
immediately look at how much do I say by
doing it this way versus this way look
it as a system a system that's got to
move from individual units of care
provided to people to optimizing the
health of people within a population I
would just add that impossible I'd like
for us to kind of commit to making this
easy make it easy for the patients to
connect make it easy for the providers
to engage in because that that's really
that's what's really going to get more
buy-in and it's really going to be able
to improve that access and the quality
and the satisfaction then as you
mentioned in the beginning well thank
you so much to all the panelists for
your insights and thoughts and thank you
for joining us I'd like to encourage
everyone to continue the conversation on
the forum website as Lisa mentioned and
I'd also like to mention that the next
panel opioid painkiller abuse and the
crisis will take place this Monday May
18th at 12:30 p.m.
please watch at forum HS pH dot work and
thank you thank you